right now I go to this like outdoor gym
I was at a regular gym for a while and I
realize like I'm living in Los Angeles
it's so nice out and I found this like
park gym where there's just a bunch of
bars and stuff and and so I go there and
I just do a lot of pull-ups and a lot of
like push-ups and cosmetics and stuff
and I stretch a little and and I try to
do more pull-ups every time and get some
Sun and then and then I run home I'm
trying to get like in one one go I can
do like 20 like for I'm trying to get to
like 30 that's my goal gotta have goals
we met at this um if this shoot for a
friend of mine named Avery but I was
like do we have the same last name like
it's crazy I don't think we're related
he was like yeah man that's nuts and
it's also funny because everybody thinks
Dan Schneider is this guy who did a lot
of Nickelodeon stuff like everything
from like all that to drinking Josh to
all those shows and so everybody thinks
they're like I didn't go to him because
my dad is Dan Schneider and funny enough
my dad is Dan Schneider but it's a
different Dan Schneider so I'm not
related to that day an eider either so
it's all very confusing but in the end
I'm not related to Rob Schneider we're
all just sharing that good old Schneider
last name and trying to make the monster
Curt I don't know if you guys know but
Curt can play six games of chess at once
blindfolded you know he's a genius he
went to he went to Yale so one time we
had a game in my house there's two games
at once to him blindfolded beat both of
us and we played good games too and he
he demolished dust blindfolded it's all
about knowing when you're gonna see each
other next for sure you have to know
there's gotta be even if it's six months
away you have to have that one date you
know and doing cute things when you
don't think it matters like sending a
random gift or sending flowers to her
house or whatever it is like just on a
random day I think that's important
because we're not seeing each other
every day
random things like that reminds you why
you're with this one person it might be
far away
the different people that come up to me
I'd like never sometimes it's like young
people are like 12 or 13 and then
sometimes I was in this Starbucks
I looked under this one I was in the
Starbucks in like an airport and I'm
standing there and I'm waiting for the
drink and the guys like Mex Nita and I
was like I was like yeah he's like wait
you are you to house like word man like
this guy like this like 35 year old guy
at Starbucks is like yeah I keep doing
this stuff and I left I just didn't
think that would happen so it's as like
that kind of stuff happens sometimes
it's definitely different in a lot of
ways for sure I definitely feel like
people who watch my YouTube stuff
definitely know me and in a very you
know genuine sense but I've also been
really lucky that a lot of the
Nickelodeon stuff I did I really just
played myself with like little different
character differences but I really try
to keep it as real as possible
you know um my one thing is I talked
about doing it right now and I try to
not really have a filter because I feel
like you could tell when things are
scripted and and I really want people to
get a sense of me my thing is being an
actor being a singer you never know when
things are gonna come and the beautiful
thing about YouTube is you make your own
and you make your own schedules you make
your own videos you really get to
express yourself and share what you're
doing with people on your time on your
schedule and for me I love being able to
control that know that like I can put a
video up every week no matter what else
is going on in traditional media there's
so many incredible things you can do
that you might not be able to do in
YouTube but it's not it's not as you
know it's not as as personable and I
love YouTube because it's very
personable like that it's your own PR in
a way it's your own you're telling the
public what's going on so it's it's
really great to have that and have that
to one be able to just use it and
I've got my album coming out nothing
without love and I'm really excited for
that I've been working on that for about
a year and a half now and then I just
found out that the pilot for NBC just
got picked up for a full series so I'm
really pumped for that it's called
crisis and it's this action political
thriller where basically I go to this
school with like the president's son and
a lot of very powerful people's kids and
get kidnapped and they use the kids to
manipulate the government through all of
these powerful CEOs and the president
all these people there's all these
twists and turns and and the task
doesn't even know where it's gonna go
cuz everyone's like I tell people about
what the full pilot is but the full
pilot I tell people about it and they're
like they're like so what's gonna happen
next and I'm like I don't know it's
gonna be crazy
so I'm excited for that and moving to
Chicago you know I've been there before
I've been there like two times and I've
some good friends there and and I'm
excited you know you got to take these
opportunities in life you just gotta
grab them you're gonna go for it so I'm
excited to see what it's like to live in
a new city and it's sort of New York
esque so I can walk around that's one
thing I miss being in LA I can't walk
everywhere like in New York so Chicago's
somewhere in the middle where I can walk
along to places and take the subway and
stuff so I'm excited for it it's it's
it's an amazing opportunity and even
though at times you feel like wow my
whole life's about to change and what
I'm going to do about that you just you
know yeah just go for it people always
said when I even first started the
Knicks shout they're like do you feel
are you gonna are you scared like what
if the show goes for like six years and
you can't break out and I guess even
knowing that I was I was like well I'm
excited it's a cool show I'm really
excited to do it and I think that in the
end if you can just accept your past and
know that I did that and I love that I
loved everything I've done in the
collodion and knowing that you know you
work hard and you can be your best and
hopefully do something new and that's
just the mentality I've had I like
worried in some ways like maybe I won't
get this role because of that but
otherwise I'm like if if they like me
and this work speaks for itself then
hopefully they'll see past that and
they'll see that maybe I have a future
and doing something more dramatic or
doing something in more of their vein of
work so that's sort of how I've thought
about it just
like let the work speak for itself you
know yes I just took this off so if I
have this on in the rest of the minute
you will know why it's so tough because
I get I get somewhat lectures from
people a lot about like you want to do
music and acting you have to choose I'm
like why do you have to choose you know
for me my philosophy is like I got this
one life I want to do these things and
like give it my all and hopefully be
able to do what makes me happy and and I
you know I really admire the careers of
like Justin Timberlake and people like
that who you know I think Justin
Timberlake is like such a nice guy like
you can tell that he's just a kind
person and does it and does anything he
wants to do and just gives it his all
all - you know people might be like oh
he's not a Daniel day-lewis well
whatever he's done great projects and
been you know great in them in my
opinion and then he can get out there
and sing and dance and like be awesome
and for that's definitely something that
I aspire to someday do if in my ideal
world if I could like do this series and
on a hiatus go like on a tour for from
an album and then come back and do like
a little movie and then come in I would
just be awesome so I hope that I can you
know keep working hard and and try to
make that happen for real
so I went in so I'd never done really a
lot of like major modeling stuff before
I was always too short for it and I had
done some photography stuff but I I met
this guy because they wanted to do this
piece on actors in New York for this GQ
Italy thing and I ended up be I was 17
at the time they wanted someone over 18
but he was like I'll keep you in mind so
a couple weeks later he calls me up he's
like can you go to this casting right
now that's right after school I was like
yeah okay so I walked down I walk and I
see it says dolce gabbana I'm like I'm
not gonna get this alright they take
three Polaroids I leave I'm like alright
well that was fun and I go get a haircut
right after this was a Friday I got a
call on Tuesday from the guy in class
he's like hey Mack so check it out you
sort of you sort of booked that Madonna
thing and I like didn't know this guy
well and I was like no way I was like
this is a sketchy no way did I book them
and he's like no you you sort of did
this is the deal so she's chosen you but
the cast director has chosen another boy
so you're gonna both show up tomorrow
and they're gonna look at you and
they're gonna see which one they want to
use so it was like the most conflicted
feeling I have I was like what does that
mean like I was like did I I don't know
like I got a what am I gonna do tomorrow
so whole night like couldn't sleep I was
freaking out I get to the set craziest
set I've ever seen like black walls
barricades around this church crazy men
in black security just like guarding the
doors that's like this is crazy I walk
up to this guy I'm like hi I'm looking
for you no supposed to choose for the
dosing about me so come on in max yeah I
was like okay
get inside nobody speaks English Italian
or Japanese I don't speak Italian
Japanese I'm walking around and
everybody's talking about like I just
want to know where they're gonna this is
gonna go down are they gonna choose us
so I'm looking around there's all these
like busky Italian men with like facial
hair and I was like 17 with no facial
and I'm just like is that guy like going
up against me cuz I hope not cuz that's
like that's crazy so anyway after you
know hours of fittings and they're doing
my hair and all this stuff all in a
different language
finally this British guy comes tries
this suit on me and it doesn't fit at
all it's huge so we use this old la
costume shop suit which I used for the
entire campaign which was in Dolce
Gabanna which was crazy to me but we did
that and it fit perfectly it was like a
sign and anyway I walk into the room I
was only supposed to do this one shot
with her I'm dancing with her and she's
she's supposed to be like my mother and
I'm supposed to kind of discuss that
she's dancing with me and so we're doing
the shots with her standing and um and I
asked the stand and she's Australian I'm
like oh my gosh you speak English do you
know what's going on like are they
choosing people and she's like has
nobody talked to you all morning and I'm
like no and they're like yeah that other
guide they called him last night and
they told him they'd let him go you've
had the job all day and I was like what
and like literally like so I just take a
sense so finally I'm like saw that I'm
doing this day this is happening
ten seconds later she's like oh
go walks out of the room and boom just
like Madonna just walks in with her
coconut water drinking coconut water
puts it down it's this tiny little
bathroom and I'm kind of freaking out
like yeah that's her like what she just
walks up to me and I'm like hi I'm Matt
she's like hi doesn't even say her name
because this is that I've done enough so
she's like starts dancing with me and I
have this disgusted look on my face and
she's like why are you making that face
and I was like I know what I want what
face do you want me to make
and she was like pulls my back up like
this and she's like I'll teach you how
to dance and so the whole so after that
I was only supposed to be that one shot
but she was like Matt come on and I
ended up being in five out of the seven
shots for the campaign she just brought
me to them and they like worked around
and we did all this new stuff and and
they said it like the whole day it was
just like I felt I was in a dream I was
like is this going on what's going on
and the photographer was like yeah you
guys have the same know she's like
that's why I chose him and it's just
like I will never forget her saying that
and that whole day and I left and I
walked out of the building and then like
got in my car to leave and I was like
wow that was real okay and after that I
like I haven't seen her since but I was
walking down the street New York one day
and her this woman comes out to me she's
like max what's up but I'm like hi I
don't know you she's like on Madonna's
trainer I saw those shots and we talked
about was like you talked about it and
that's the last time I've really like
talked to someone in that crew so that's
the story